we all know that we shouldn't skip leg
day it can lead to muscle imbalances it
reduces the amount of calories we burn
at rest it can even reduce your
musculature plus it doesn't look great
if you've got a massive upper body and
tiny little chicken legs and your legs
are actually far more important than
your upper body for the majority of
athletic performance whether it's
running whether it's jumping or even
providing a stable base to push off of
when you are exerting force through your
pecs and shoulders but whilst we all
know that we shouldn't skip leg day
skipping leg day is nevertheless so
common that it's become practically a
meme so why is this well there's a few
reasons and one of the first ones must
be that training legs from home is
really rather difficult perception is
that you need a lot of weight to train
your legs which means you're going to
need a barbell packed with weight and
you're going to need a power rack at the
same time a lot of people find that
training their legs is kind of awkward
and difficult they might have knee pain
or back pain so they don't want to load
a whole load of weight on their backs
they don't want to bend over too far and
they might just find that they feel a
bit uncomfortable anytime they get down
into a squat but never fear the bioneer
is here and i'm here to tell you that
there are actually lots of exercises you
can do for legs that don't require that
much weight that don't feel really
uncomfortable that most people can
perform and it will build athleticism
speed stability balance and better
looking wheels all at the same time
without further ado let's get started
it is fresh out here today so without
beating around the bush let's get on to
the first exercise that being weighted
jump squats so for this you're going to
need a light pair of weights or a single
light dumbbell
ideally this should be about 30 of your
body weight because according to the
research this is what's going to
contribute most to an increased jump
height and running speed anything
heavier than that you need to grind
through the movement it slows you down
this has just the right amount of
resistance to increase the load on your
body without really sewing things down
so you're going to pick them up if
you've got dumbbells you're going to
hold them by your sides if you've got a
kettlebell you're going to hold it like
a goblet squat right in front of you
there by the handle and then you're just
going to squat down and then leap up and
i want you to really focus on driving
through your feet really explosively and
getting as high as you can as fast as
you can
this is essentially compensatory
acceleration a technique used by some
power lifters when you don't have a lot
of weight you can use speed instead
because that still requires force and as
far as your body's concerned forces
force if you're primarily interested in
performance and explosiveness then the
advice is to wait at least three times
as long as it took you to perform the
set during recovery so that you can
re-engage all those fast twitch fibers
the next time you come to perform the
set but if you're more interested in
hypertrophy perhaps a little bit of
metabolic conditioning then you don't
need to worry about that so much we can
do what i like to do to get the best of
both worlds which is to create a
mechanical drop set we perform the
highly explosive movements at the
beginning then you just drop the weight
and you carry on of course what's really
important is that you land softly you
don't want to jarringly land hard on
your knees you need to really need to
absorb that impact on your feet and your
knees gently on the way back down each
time so practice this without weights if
you're not used to it and then build up
to this if you have any bad knees etc or
bad back this probably isn't the
exercise for you i'm doing this on grass
for preference which obviously makes
life a little bit easier as well if you
do want to use a kettlebell in the
goblet position as opposed to dumbbells
on either side of your body this also
becomes an anti-flexion movement you're
preventing your body from bending
forwards thereby engaging the muscles in
the erector spinae and the hips and this
is going to translate to an even higher
jump height because that triple
extension when you jump normally you're
driving your upper body up as well so
we're practicing that at the same time
placing a little bit of resistance there
as well but either will work really
nicely
another really simple movement you can
perform if you want to train your legs
at home is just squats air squats lots
and lots of squats the squat has tons of
benefits i'll probably do a breakdown of
the squat in a future video let me know
if that's something you'd like to see
but basically when you're squatting
you're performing a fundamental human
movement pattern and at the same time
because it's closed chain because it's
very safe you're able to perform high
repetitions without fatigue and without
risk of injury don't worry too much
about having a massive range of motion
here the aim is to maintain continuous
time under tension this is something
i've been preaching for a while and it's
not the kind of thing you'll often hear
building a good range of motion is
really important but this is a separate
thing whereby performing high high
repetitions can actually allow you to
improve muscle growth your strength
endurance because strength injuries in
the legs is of course really important
it's gonna strengthen your tendons and
it might even increase blood supply to
the muscles allowing you to train for
longer and harder and improving your
recovery even building up more satellite
cells this is how we know that a lot of
prisoner workouts programmed their leg
training i mean that mike tyson built
massive powerful legs this way just give
it a go and i think you're gonna feel
that it really does do something
especially if you're combining it with
heavier movements and explosive
movements and more challenging single
leg movements than you're getting the
best of every world if high high
repetition body weight squats is
something that you struggle with and
it's perfectly fine if you do this can
be the result of ankle mobility or knee
problems or hip mobility etc then
another solution often is to once again
use these squat blocks and whilst i do
recommend working up to a natural deep
resting squat these can be useful once
again if you just want to bash out lots
of volume if you're focusing more on
just pure strength pure strength
endurance metabolic conditioning etc and
that'll just make it a lot easier for
you to get a whole lot done
and to build really strong legs
speaking of squats if you're looking for
an exercise that's genuinely difficult
no matter what your experience level is
then look no further than the pistol
squats this of course is a one-legged
squat ideally you want to perform it
with your heel on the floor and the
other leg sticking out in front of you
and you're going to push yourself up off
that one leg not only does this mean
you're taking your entire body weight on
one leg of course it's also a mobility
challenge as you need to not topple
backwards meaning you need great ankle
mobility you need a strong spine to stay
upright and at the same time it's a
balance challenge of course because
you're stabilizing yourself on that one
leg if this still isn't hard enough you
can of course add a little bit of weight
but you just for a few repetitions
you're gonna feel it almost no matter
who you are
and of course if it's too difficult you
can use a rope and hold on to that or a
wall you can hang one leg off of a ledge
or something or you can even use a
friend to help assist you on the way
back up or you can perform as many as
you can normally and then get the friend
to assist you wearing heels or using a
squat block
such as one of these can help you to
reduce the mobility challenge so you can
pump out more repetitions if you're just
looking for that performance this isn't
something that you should be doing for
high high repetitions you're not in a
stable position so it shouldn't be used
as conditioning it should be used more
to build the movement pattern stability
on that one leg and a little bit of
strength as well again you can perform
this near the start of a workout and
follow up with some regular air squads
for a real pump
okay now the next one is fantastic for
improving your movement patterns for
preventing back pain from making more
athletic this is all good stuff yes i'm
talking about the glute bridge a
favorite of the glute guy rhett
contreras and shown in many studies to
be highly beneficial for athletes what
we're doing here is we're going to be
thrusting the hips towards the sky
whilst lying on our backs driving
through the heel and trying to engage
the glutes that's the butt as we do
if you feel this in your quads then that
might mean that you're quad dominant
which means that you're using your quads
more often than your glutes for
movements like running and jumping and
this is
not optimal for your maximum performance
at the same time might mean that your
glutes are weak inactive and this can
mean that your spine ends up coming
under undue pressure so this is a
fantastic way to
find out whether your glutes are working
the way they're supposed to and to fix
that if they're not at the same time i'm
going to be targeting them and really
driving power through them which can
result in more powerful movement when
you're standing up as well so to perform
this you're going to lie on the ground
what you ideally want to do is find the
muddiest coldest wettest piece of ground
you can find try and avoid the cat poo
and that's a perfect spot to do your
glute bridges you're going to
rest your weight on your shoulders and
you're going to bring your hips up
towards the sky
by driving through the heels of your
foot and engaging the glutes now if you
do feel this in your quads or your back
and not your glutes there are a few
little changes you can make to try and
improve that the first one is to focus
more on driving upwards and driving
through the heel another is to try
clenching the buttocks as you go and yet
another is to
get something to brace your legs and to
try and drive your legs outwards at the
same time pushing through the ground
which will help to engage the glutes
that little bit more you can do this by
using a resistance band that's what i've
seen but i find that this isn't strong
enough
or it's painful if it is and so i've
actually been using a yoga wheel to
achieve the same thing and over time you
should find that you naturally engage
the glutes more than the quads and then
you're going to engage them more through
all kinds of other movements reducing
back pain making you stronger faster all
that good stuff you can also try
bringing your heels close to your butt
this is also going to help you to engage
the glutes that little bit more
and of course the more difficult
variation is either to place a weight
here
or to raise one leg
off the ground
like so
just took a break for now with my family
to have lunch and look what came in the
post in the meantime an amazon delivery
of one outdoors yoga mat i don't know
why i didn't think of this idea much
sooner but i could have used it about an
hour ago anyways from now on you'll have
the more professional sight of me not
getting myself covered in mud when i
demonstrate exercises outside that
involve lying on the ground another of
my favorite leg exercises at the moment
is the romanian deadlift or rdl here's
an exercise that's essentially the top
half of a deadlift so you're not bending
at the knees to pick up the weight
instead you're just lowering as far as
you can go and then standing straight
back up by hinging the hips what you
want to focus on here is pushing the
butt outwards as you go to correctly
hinge the hips rather than bending the
back to bend forwards which is not what
we want here you can practice this with
something called butt touches which is
where you stand by a fence or a wall and
literally just move your butt backwards
and try touching against that wall like
that you're going to let your legs bend
slightly but the point is not to bend
the legs so it's just what's natural
here and you'll know doing it right
because when you reach a certain point
you should feel a nice stretch on the
hamstrings and this is the point where
you're going to stop and then reverse
the movement and stand back up by once
again bringing the hips forwards and
then you're going to repeat the movement
to keeping the back straight all the
while this is a great stretch for the
hamstrings it's also a great workout for
the hamstrings and it's teaching you an
important movement pattern so it's tons
of bang for your buck and it's another
one that can help prevent back pain and
improve your athletic performance highly
recommended and you don't need that much
weight and you can do it perfectly fine
with dumbbells or kettlebell
if you want to do something to target
the calves specifically and this isn't a
bad idea then something like a calf
raise particularly a deficit car phrase
so you're keeping the heel lower than
the ball of the foot to begin with is a
great way to not only strengthen the
cast through a wide range of motion but
also to strengthen and develop the
achilles tendon which is really good
news and you can improve your balance if
you focus on trying to do this with one
leg and without supporting yourself on a
wall obviously if you're focused more on
strength and endurance then do it with
both legs and your hands on a wall add
some weight if you like but if you also
want to get a little bit of balance
training in there as well especially for
your feet then you can try doing it on
one foot which is an added bonus next up
the split squat made famous by knees
over toes guy this is a great exercise
not only because it strengthens the
knees because you're allowing your knee
to go past the toes but also because it
stretches the hip flexors which is
something that are tight in a lot of us
thanks to all that sitting it's also
great for ankle mobility as you're
leaning over that front toe you can lean
over the front toe or you can come up
onto your toes to take the knee further
or you can do a little bit of bow this
will help you with your jumping height
with your resilience
it can even help you develop your
scissor splits
so you're coming forwards in a kind of
diagonal downwards movement
letting your knees go as far past the
toes as you can and if you want to you
can also go that little bit further
to really get that stretch on the hip
flexor so the exercise i just want to
finish on real quickly is the cossack
squat here you're going to squat down on
just one side with your other leg
stretched out to the side this is a nice
hip stretch but the other reason it's so
important is that it's a movement in the
frontal plane in other words moving side
to side instead of forwards and
backwards and up and down we move in all
planes of motion all the time especially
in sports but also just in daily life so
it's really important that we train in
all planes of motion as well so many leg
routines simply focus on squats and
variations of squats and they don't look
at moving left and right etc and this
can be a big mistake essentially
likewise you want to work on building
single leg strength and explosive
strength just develop every aspect of
our leg performance the great thing is
that as we've seen you can do all of
that from home
really nice and easily with relatively
lightweight minimal equipment you can do
it in your living room or in a garden
that's covered in cat poo there's really
no reason you can't train your legs and
if you have any difficulties with
mobility etc all these exercises can be
adjusted a squat can be performed with
your arms on a chair for example or you
can even lift yourself up have a spot to
help you we can use squat blocks if you
lack range of motion or weight lifting
shoes there's plenty of options and no
excuse for skipping leg day
with just these exercises you can build
a full routine adapt it to your own
level do it from anywhere and hopefully
that's enough to get you started but
there's plenty more i could have
included and again these are movements
that are adaptable can be done from
anywhere you can do farmers walks in
your garden just doing laps of the
garden holding weights you can do it on
one side if you want to strengthen the
quadratus lumborum if you want to build
that oblique strength we can do on both
sides if you just want pure trap
strength and you want to focus on hip
stability and walking you can do single
leg jump squats if you have the balance
and stability this is very cool because
you normally explode off of one leg not
two in most situations you can do
skipping to build more car strength and
ankle stiffness which translates to
faster sprint times you know the hindu
squats are among my favorites a slightly
gentler way for training than these
[ __ ] squats take that a bit further but
i also actually really rate them as long
as you ease into them really nice and
carefully nordic curls bit difficult to
set up absolutely insane for your
hamstring development and of course the
kettlebell swing itself which translates
to better jump height running speed
people talk about the what the hell
effects just because it does so much
good stuff i'm gonna make a whole video
on that in future so i haven't gone into
it in depth here let me know your
favorite leg exercises in the comments
down below and how you train your legs
from home and stay tuned for more like
this hope you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share around if you
like this kind of training that looks
not just at your appearance and your
physique but also your performance the
way you move mobility strength endurance
even brain function then you'll enjoy my
ebook and training program super
functional training and like this
workout all of that is designed to be
done from home with minimal equipment
there's even a minimal equipment version
of the routine included in the package
so check that out let me know your
favorite leg exercises in the comments
down below and how you train your legs
from home please subscribe and hit the
bell button if you want to be notified
of future uploads that's actually one of
the very best things you can do to
support the channel so massively
appreciated but as always i appreciate
you just for watching thank you so much
see you next time
bye for now